[Applause]
really welcome back Rossi when it comes
to healthy sweets do get a little Loca
do I get Loca I don't just get Loca
honey I get banana Loca and that's why
for today's in a minute we're
celebrating National Banana Day by
teaming up with banana Loca everyone's
talking about it
it is this gadget it was actually
featured on Shark Tank and Kevin O'Leary
himself is an investor here's what it
does it fills your banana with any
spread of your choice and today we're
going to do a little taste test all
right all right we've got some bananas
here this one's been filled up with some
uh chocolate hazelnut spread okay I
would like to put peanut butter
um oh that's a good idea you want to try
it
how good is that so good it's beyond
right it really is I do want one with
peanut butter however okay I mean I'm
not going to be satisfied until I put
peanut butter in this banana what's in
this one well it's not peanut butter and
the next time I'm getting you a peanut
butter one this is filled with mallow
marshmallow no oh what is it it's filled
with cottage cheese
what I love is that you can experiment
okay whatever sounds good to you you try
it we're trying cottage cheese let's see
I think it's good my mom used to take
bananas and dip them in sour cream and
bacon bits and I was like that's
disgusting
and then she had me try it and I was
like oh it's good well it actually
sounds bananas
but Drew what do you think isn't this a
great invention you can just create you
can express yourself
everyone in our studio audience is gonna
go home with their own banana Loca
[Applause]
[Music]